so OnePlus made a tablet and I made a
quick short explaining it and
immediately there are a bunch of
comments like oh please this is worth a
full video please make a full video on
this please elaborate on this so now
that's what I'm doing so I really get to
explain what they've done see tablets
haven't really changed much over the
past couple years feels like we've kind
of settled if you will into this sort of
hierarchy where especially in the US
iPads are so popular that it's basically
just iPads and everything else and I've
even had conversations recently with
some friends about this which is just
like they straight up won't switch from
the iPad like no matter how good of a
competitor comes up it can be amazing
Hardware it can be the best screen the
best battery in the world it's an
amazing tablet
but it still wouldn't be an iPad which
is the iMessage and the FaceTime and all
the things that plug into the ecosystem
of iPad and apple world so making an
Android tablet that can actually take
users from the iPad is clearly an uphill
battle but hey if you're gonna try you
might as well have some strategy to it
and so OnePlus has three so strategy
number one copying the iPad so look just
to be clear I understand there's only so
many ways to make a rectangular computer
there's only so many ways to make a
tablet uh and I actually don't mind when
products copy each other as long as they
copy the good stuff
that being said yeah they've ripped some
stuff straight from the iPad now it does
have its own unique Hardware aesthetic
you got to give them that it's a
different shape and a different color
and of course it's a different layout
with a bunch of OnePlus and Android
features that really suggest more
holding it in landscape unlike the iPads
which feel a bit more interchangeable
but they weren't shy about some things
like this pencil this is the apple
pencil and this is the new OnePlus
pencil same shape same size same
pressure sensitive tip which is nice
same single flat side which prevents it
from Rolling away on a table which is
smart but then same slapping onto the
side of a tablet with magnets and
charging it by inductive wireless
charging so you don't lose it it's
convenient it even has the same little
animation to show you when you've paired
it and how much battery percentage you
have there are probably other ways to do
this but you know the result is just a
very familiar experience with a nice
finely controlled pressure sensitive
pointing device for navigating around
and swiping and even typing and of
course all the drawing and note taking
you possibly want they've also made a
magnetic keyboard accessory with a
trackpad that can connects to the tablet
with magnets and these pins and turns it
into a whole lappable Android 11 inch
laptop alternative it might not
completely float the tablet above the
keyboard like the heavier less lappable
one from Apple but it does use basically
the exact same cursor mechanism as the
iPad where you can swipe around with
this dark circle and then it snaps onto
different touch targets As you move near
them again a pretty great thing to copy
it's got quad speakers in the same four
spots as the iPad Pro it's even got this
Ultra wide camera at the front that has
a software feature that can move around
as you walk around and keep you in the
center of the frame it's not called
Center Stage though it's called
Limelight the point is there's a ton of
stuff here where if you're going to take
people away from the iPad you gotta at
least make them feel at home so then
strategy number two undercutting the
iPad this one's pretty simple the iPad
line is already pretty expensive so
probably the most compelling thing you
can do to get someone to consider an
alternative is to be cheaper than the
iPad so iPad Air I think that's a pretty
good comp iPad Air starts right now with
the newest one at 5.99 and that's the 64
gig version this tablet as we mentioned
pretty fairly priced 479 and that's 128
gig so you can see it's a pretty good
start but
you have to be careful because in order
to get to that price you have to trim
just the right set of things that people
hopefully don't notice too much so this
tablet is running a mediatek demensity
9000 chip which benchmarks similar to
the Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 which is
about 50 beneath the more expensive
Flagship Snapdragon 8 gen 2. honestly
most of the time not noticeable but if
you are going to ask it some more
demanding things especially like gaming
then you will feel that this is not the
highest end chip there is also no
fingerprint reader which is fine but
there's also no extra infrared or depth
sensors it's just straight up facial
recognition with the standard RGB selfie
camera and for some reason my face has
to be really close to it to unlock it's
just picky enough to get slightly
annoying sometimes and then this display
doesn't quite get as bright it maxes out
at 500 nits so it limits your outdoor
usability for sure and then this
keyboard case which is optional it's
actually noticeably cheaper than Apples
too it's actually 149 so it's literally
half the price of the magic keyboard but
also it's not back lit it doesn't float
the tablet or anything it's also less
premium feeling material so it's more in
line with the smart folio case which is
still 179 but really the most
interesting strategy strategy number
three is one-upping the iPad there are
some things they've done with this
tablet that are objectively better than
any iPad okay so here we go first of all
this is an 11.5 inch display with a
unique slightly tall seven by five
aspect ratio and slightly thinner bezels
on the iPad but you know what's straight
up better than any iPad it's 144 Hertz
refresh rate granted that's only
slightly higher than 120 hertz iPad Pro
but for 479 I mean you're more in line
with the 60 hertz iPad Air and I'm a
sucker for a high refresh rate display
and I do notice the difference in a few
key places like scrolling around
browsing in Chrome and drawing with the
pen but more on that in a second the
ultra wide front facing camera is on the
landscape bezel that's also better than
almost every iPad except for the newest
cheap one so anytime you're on a video
call you actually sit in the middle of
the frame not kind of awkwardly off to
one side it also is an objectively
better battery than any iPad this is a 9
500 10 milliamp hour battery that's iPad
Pro sized and combined with the chip has
Rock Solid battery life and very good
standby time and it charges much faster
than any iPad it's got 67 watt supervook
charging so most of the tablet using
world is going to be used to the iPad's
kind of slow 30 watts of charging this
one can charge from zero to 100 in an
hour and a half with the charger that's
included in the box and then there's
also this whole special features section
in the settings where they've tucked
these nice clever little enhancements
mostly to do with the multitasking
experience so I'm not even going to
remind you of the disaster that is stage
manager on the iPad that's still kind of
rough but on the OnePlus pad you can do
things like drag two fingers down from
the middle of the screen to slice your
app in half and initiate split screen
multitasking with apps that support it
and then there's three different window
sizes that it supports and you can
switch those around there's also a smart
side bar that kind of slides out from
the top right where it's this hidden
dock so you can put your favorite apps
in there or some quick shortcuts to grab
whatever you want or just open up the
list of all your apps again so lots of
good stuff in here right even they've
even got some little ecosystem stuff
going on since OnePlus makes phones you
can do data sharing with another OnePlus
phone super easily there's a lot
but
this is still an Android tablet which
means a lot of things it means of course
that there is no FaceTime iMessage all
the ecosystem stuff that comes that
Apple people like
obviously
but that also means the app situation is
still not what you want it to be like
when I say apps that support it with
multitasking that's a pretty small list
like there's just very few good
well-optimized Android tablet apps even
today in 2023
it also means that the 144hz capable
display is rarely actually uh refreshing
at 144hz it's often at 120 hertz or even
60 hertz depending on the app support
again uh and that sort of means you only
really get the extra stuff when you're
scrolling around the UI or web browsing
or in the settings app basically and not
while gaming it also means the cameras
are meh so you see the the camera is
sort of in this unique layout in the
middle it's a 13 megapixel camera on the
back but the photos it takes are pretty
mid not that a tablet is like some
photography machine it's mostly for
video calls but even this is pretty
grainy it has this like splotching even
in a well-lit environment not great and
then for the arguably even more
important selfie camera it's it's mostly
for video calls and so it should look
pretty decent this is perfect lighting
and even in these dark shadows you can
see some weird noise artifacts and
splotching and and this over here it
it's 1080P and it's it's fine it's
probably fine but in Limelight mode when
it's doing the ultra wide and hunting
around it looks worse than this too and
it also means that Android 14 is on the
horizon so that will probably improve a
lot of the multitasking stuff we just
saw but this one's going to launch with
Android 13. so if you get one it'll have
Android 13 and never buy a product based
on potential future software updates so
as of right now it's an Android 13
tablet so OnePlus has made a good tablet
for a good price I think a lot of people
consider this a bargain f479 for the 128
gigs but because of this data tablets it
feels like they're up against some
impossible task like this is the same
thing that happened to Samsung's Ultra
tablet remember the video I made on the
ultra the Galaxy Tab S8 Ultra tried
something super super high end and
honestly in the hardware and design
department they really beat the iPad in
a lot of ways they made an incredible
piece but same question where is it now
I think the same place as this
some people are going to buy it and
they're going to be pretty happy with it
and those people knew exactly what they
were getting into
and it's a tough task taking tablet
buyers from the iPad
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
foreign